welcome back to las vegas now it's
almost taco tuesday and it smells so
good in here and pinches tacos knows how
to celebrate right
now to show us what's on the menu this
smells incredible you know video has
become a trend i know you guys all see
it with the cheese and the dipping and
whatnot well growing up mexican is
symbolic to weddings quinceaneras
because when we had to throw a party for
a few hundred people and you were po
you know we had to feed a lot of people
so we didn't have a per person thing
like oh it's 50 a person we're like we
could afford that goat and that goat so
for any party we had we had to feed what
2 300 people so it's something that's
more of our tradition now it's a trend
that is going a little wrong because
it's about the actual meat okay now
people want you to dip it and they want
you to put cheese and it just adds
saltiness
and why is ours better than everyone
else's because we have chella in the
kitchen yes no one has chella but us so
you are doing something right and i
can't wait any longer i want you to make
this
some people use goat because of the
gaminess and that's what we did growing
up
but now we're able to do it with beef
because a lot of people don't do goat
and you know there's a certain gaminess
that comes with it so we throw in the
bones and that's where all the gaminess
comes from so yes yes i like that okay
we're topping it off with some onions
and
some cilantro and a little lime
to cut through the fat then as you're
preparing this we're just talking about
it a minute ago but this is something
new that you've added to the menu
we were holding off again because it was
just a trend right it's something that
we grew up eating and to me that we're
doing it for all right and this is kind
of a secret menu item it's not printed
anywhere you only know well now we're
telling all of our audience out there
watching it they say you want the tutti
frutti fresh and fruity
i was like is that the the secret word
and i'm gonna take a bite of it but you
guys are also known for your margaritas
and your cocktails what did you bring
with us we have our our famous one our
house the blood orange we have
watermelon and we just introduced guava
guava with the tahini you guys and we
make ours
smooth but like i said last time i was
here they kind of slap you at the same
i'm saying you're like oh how time you i
love it
and you guys are located inside the
gramercy gramercy yeah we have three
locations here we have henderson uh
downtown and gramercy
taking over the city one taco at a time
one taco at a time i like that slogan
okay i'm going to help myself to this
because it sounds amazing but take a
bite of this and while she does that i'm
going to take something okay cheers look
at the juiciness
let's see if i can eat it gracefully
yeah it's just cheers let's do it okay
we're going in
at that
am i doing something right if it's all
over my face
it's all about the juice it's delicious
thank you for being here thank you for
having us we'll be right back